Hello everyone,
welcome to the lange focus channel.
Uh,
my name is Paul.
Today's video is the second installment
in the series mystery languages.
If you haven't seen the first video in
the mystery language,
a series,
you can check it out right here,
but basically this is how it works.
I will play you an audio sample of a
language and then I'll show you a visual
samples of the language and it's written
for them and you can guess what language
it is,
but whether you guessed correctly or
not,
that doesn't matter.
The important thing is that you leave
your guesses and the reasons for your
guesses in the comments down below and
that will spark some interesting
discussion.
So let's get right into the first
language.
Please listen,
I'm bidding in a pile in the middle one
upon which enabled me to pronounce away
Nomia Sheila.
I'm a building and some peanut volcker
to Monica,
but the upper market but Lukla bond.
Okay.
Lions are going to.
Now let's have a look at a few written
samples of that same language.
Nema,
Nina Harland.
Cool.
But don't they?
So what language do you think it is?
The language is a language spoken on the
island of Cebu in the Philippines.
If you guessed together,
log or Filipino,
which is the official language which is
based on Tagalog,
then that's a pretty good guests because
to Gallaghan Silvano are closely related
languages I've studied together.
Again,
I'm fairly familiar with it and when I
look at Sidwell I know sometimes I don't
know if I'm looking at Tagalog with lots
of vocabulary,
I don't know or whether I'm looking at
say Bono said we wanna was sometimes
referred to as Bisiah,
which is actually a group of closely
related languages that are spoken in the
Visayas region in the Philippines,
but some people like to refer to all the
languages as a single language with
different dialects and that's because
all the Bisiah languages are quite
closely related.
But also because.
Well there's power in numbers.
You may have noticed the Spanish
vocabulary in the sample sentences.
That's because it has lots of Spanish
long words just like to Gallo does in
fact several one or has even more
Spanish words meant together.
Okay.
Onto the second language,
please listen.
They get food when he's sad,
her warm up so they can meet,
meet and whole manual,
mundane,
poem.
They put handcuffs,
put him to hold still
and again.
Let's have a look at some written
samples.
Yeah,
I guess
so.
What language is it?
It's the loud language.
Lao is a language spoken in the
Southeast Asian nation of Laos.
It's a member of the Tai Chi language
family,
which is spoken in some parts of
Southeast Asia,
southern China and northern India.
If you thought the language was tied
then you were very close because ty and
Lao,
or very closely related to a large
degree,
they are mutually intelligible.
They are both tonal languages,
but one notable differences that ty has
five tones.
While Lau has six tones,
they're also written in a slightly
different script,
but the scripts themselves are also
closely related and if you can read one
than reading the others shouldn't be too
hard.
Some of you may have noticed the tones
and the language samples which make the
language sound kind of melodic,
and you might have guessed one of the
Chinese languages like Mandarin or
Cantonese,
and those guesses would make sense
because those are tonal languages.
Just like lawand tire.
Okay.
Onto the third language,
please listen.
Modify on central park.
Young Scheme will mix as a club Dj Vika
Outta the shop does issue three,
Dan
and again,
let's see a bit of the language
visually.
Schools that Cmo,
oh,
seemed more Zune genito Dr.
departure,
so what language is it?
It's the Romanian language.
If you speak any romance languages that
you've probably noticed right away that
there was a lot of romance vocabulary in
the samples,
what the pronunciation might have seemed
kind of unusual to you.
That's because Romanian is a romance
language with some Slavic influence.
That influence affects the pronunciation
and also the vocabulary of the language.
You may have also noticed the little
glyphs above the letter a and below the
letter t those glyphs or actually an
integral part of those letters and those
letters along with this,
this,
and this.
Give you a quick hint that you're
looking at Romanian and not at a
different romance language.
Romanian is spoken in Romania and
Moldova and is geographically isolated
from the other major romance languages.
The Slavic influence on the language
makes it distinct from the other romance
languages,
but Romanian is also said to be the
closest romance language to the original
Latin in grammar.
That's probably true,
but in some other areas like phonology,
it may not be as close to the original
Latin as say Italian.
Well,
I hope you enjoyed guessing today's
mystery languages.
Leave your guesses and your reasons in
the comments down below and also letting
me know if you like the series and you
think I should continue doing it.
And again,
I want to say thank you to all of my
patrion supporters for your continued
support,
especially these ones right here on the
screen for there,
especially generous pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice.